et nous sommes avec douglas y est
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines et
nicolas concoeur porte-parole des
républicaines sauveur 6 france bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france n'est que la
conquête quel regard est ce que vous me
portez sur le meeting de ce soir alors
on est très heureux tant les militants
que les responsables qui vont pouvoir
s'exprimer au devant de la scène de
pouvoir prendre ses meetings avec toute
cette ferveur toute cette énergie à plus
forte raison que s'inscrit dans un
contexte où toute la campagne électorale
de 2020 avait été complètement confisqué
souvenez-vous le candidat by donne à
l'époque lui faisait campagne dans son
sous sol
les meetings était vraiment voilà la
voiture était parti à man réduite et il
nous tarde vraiment qu'on redonne la
plaine de vocation au populaire et toute
l'énergie l'effervescence du mouvement
mag a initié par donald trump pour 2016
et qui a encore de belles années devant
lui nos glaciers sont évoque le grand
retour ce soir de donald trump vous le
voyez comme ça vous essayez oui les
démocrates doit attention à cette
campagne
le première fois qu'ils ont ignoré ces
réunions et on ne craint pas gagné et
donc maintenant c'est un danger il n'a
jamais nicolas conte guerre qu'est ce
qu'il pèse aujourd'hui dans le parti
républicain donald trump alors donald
trump c'est important de le rappeler il
a récupéré donc l'investiture du parti
républicain en 2016 alors que le parti
républicain était à ce très fractionnée
donc lui-même a réussi à l'unifier après
ce premier mandat et tous ses succès il
a capitalisé sur vraiment tout un
mouvement uni et malgré quelques franges
dissidentes qui sont les rhein aux les
républicains name only on vraiment là
des républicains plutôt opportuniste de
la vieille garde est mitt romney des
lisa murkowski différentes sénatrice qui
jouent leur poste sénat dans les
prochaines élections
donald trump se positionne vraiment en
force d' influence si peu en dehors
c'est des candidats c'est à dire
apporter son soutien et c'est une
machine à faire gagner sur l'ensemble
des parrainages qu'il a apportée il ya
eu 200 28 victoires pour 2 défaites et
simon vraiment que dans 100% des cas le
fait d'apporter le soutien de donald
trump s'apaisent concis
ra ble ment dans la balance vous le
disiez à douglas yates
cette mise en garde que vous faites à
l'égard des démocrates c'est une réelle
menace aujourd'hui
donald trump oui car comme candidat aux
présidentielles mais quelqu'un qui a une
grande bourse pour soutenir les
candidates républicaines dans les
primaires qui va venir
donc chaque deux ans un à tous les
sièges de chambre de représentants qui
sont en jeu et six d'entre eux
soutiennent quelqu'un ou aux biens fait
un ennemi de quelqu'un il quand même
quelqu'un qui est déjà dans un siège si
dangereux parce que le besse ii dans
notre ombre reste loyale à lui tous les
républicains qui ne soutiennent pas dans
notre temps sont en face tu ne risques
dans les primaires dans les élections
primaires de son colère
c'est ça le rôle que dans notre ombre
jeu maintenant il est éliminé de médias
meanstream il n'a pas la chance d'être
restitués dans son office comme il
voulait mais il a une puissance de
bourse très forte influence parce que le
parti républicain grèce du moins aux
lectures à le pratiquer d'autres est ce
qu'aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut dire à
nicolas conc'air que le parti
républicain ne tient pas son donald
trump est ce qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'élus républicains qui ose affirmer
leurs distances vis-à-vis de
l'ex-président américain comme on l'a vu
il ya encore quelques mois qu'est ce
qu'ils sont devenus ces république
est-ce qu'ils ont retourné leur veste
il y en a qui par opportunisme on essaie
de se racheter une conscience à bas
frais mais comme je le disais c'est line
aux des gens très sans colonne
vertébrale sans ossature dont je
m'attarderai pas tellement sur eux le
vrai
le vrai fond du sujet le sous titre adr
tout ça c'est donald trump s'est pas
l'incarnation du parti républicain ça va
au-delà de lui-même de sa figure il a
lancé un mouvement dans laquelle
s'inscrivent de nombreux candidats très
prometteur très jeune et qui ont
vraiment des sérieuses chances de peser
dans l'avenir politique et à court terme
dès les élections de mi-mandat en 2022
et en vue de l'investiture à la maison
blanche en 2024
ce sont là sa velléité politique il est
réellement prêts à se représenter en
une question que tout le monde à anosy
cesse de lui poser pardon je connais
conquérants viendra avec c'est une
question qu'on a eu de cesse de lui
poser figurez-vous depuis plus de 30 ans
dans les médias à l'époque c'est
quelqu'un très fréquentable il était la
coqueluche des médias
oprah winfrey chez à d'autres talk show
très très connu aux états unis il était
habité on voulait le pousser à s'engager
dans la campagne politique lui-même
était plutôt hésitants plus tôt par
intégrité et un peu frilosité par
rapport à ce monde de requins qu'est la
politique et le swing comme il
l'appelait d'ailleurs ce qu'il s'est
mobilisée à à lutter contre toute cette
politique corrompue de washington en
faisant son mouvement de john zorn là à
l'heure actuelle il ya encore trop tôt
pour se positionner en soi rien n'est
exclu à ce stade là il ya des ticket
président vice président qui pourrait
être envisagé très sérieusement et en
tout cas ils n'arrêtent pas d'acheter on
s'amuse à le dépeindre en ne jouant au
golf mais à côté de ça c'est quelqu'un
qui sait se donne corps et âme jour
après jour pour pour le pays et pour
tout cet électorat qui ont cherché à
confisquer sa voix à travers différentes
manières des censures dans les médias
sur les réseaux sociaux ou
éventuellement est le plus préoccupant
par des changements de codes électoraux
qui lisent à biaiser les les modes de
scrutin à douglas y est vous dirais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est donald trump qui
est encore au coeur du champ politique
américain oui il reste essentiel mais il
faut se méfier de sa capacité de rentrer
dans la maison blanche vous savez il est
un vaste plusieurs procès
intitulé des charges criminelles pour
évasion des cats dans les cas de new
york
les héros de justice sont très longues
aux états unis mais finalement il va
arriver dans son but et si vous verrez
son comptable experte qui est sûr le
vice du département de justice
il est très probable que cette team one
va te rencontre d'un autre en est quand
même un certain nombre des conseillers
ont déjà fait ici dans l'autre en est et
est jugé pour les affaires criminelles y
sera
il sera exclu d'une campagne
présidentielle et ne sied pas de ses
ennemis dont une partie republican qui
veulent exclure
ils n'étaient pas organisées en 2016
mais même en s'y est et la protège
républicaine dont le congrès est une
chose mais à nez dans les es 4,1 en as
menace d'un mouvement de troisième
partie de 30
et ça ça pourrait rejouer pour les élues
locales dans les états de s'organiser
pour éliminer ce moment ça vous évoquez
douglas y est ça allait poursuites
judiciaires qui pèsent contre donald
trump selon le new york times le
procureur de manhattan pourrait
officialiser l'ouverture d'une enquête
pénale contre la trump organization la
société donald trump avec en cause a les
avantages sociaux accordés par la
société à son directeur financier et à
d'autres cadres de l'entreprise ça
pourrait avoir des conséquences réelles
ans sur son
retour éventuel retour en politique je
présume que vous vous prenez un mois
donc oui s'il est si les unissant coupe
habilité pour ces crimes et ça c'est
juste le le sommet de masse en pierre de
criminalité il sera exclu
et comme les collèges sans cause et ils
soient dans une position de non
éligibilité au le présidentielle ces
poursuites judiciaires elle inquiète à
nicolas conquérants fin du parti
républicain comment est-ce qu'on voit
les choses d'une part on accepte que les
affaires se déroulent et on laisse la
justice faire son travail on néglige pas
quand même qu'il peut y avoir quelques
motivations politiques derrière
encore une fois quand on voit les
cabales qui sont effectués vers tel ou
tel candidat c'est forcément ceux qui
qui présente le plus grand danger
donc voilà c'est la realpolitik et des
basses manoeuvres
mais trump et ses équipes d'avocats
seront tout à fait en mesure de faire
face à ces accusations et de défendre
leurs leur cause alors on évoquait avec
vous aussi nicolas conc'air tout à
l'heure le poids de donald trump dans
l'électorat républicain visiblement si
l'on s'en réfère à l'échec de son blog
l'ancien après dans l'américaine soucie
pas vraiment l'intérêt donald trump qui
auront l'a rappelé a été bannie des
réseaux sociaux il était question au
printemps qu'il crée sa propre
plateforme il en est où
l'important dans cette affaire-là c'est
surtout de mètres du toit le rôle et la
super influences qu'on les médias et les
réseaux sociaux dans le choix de qui
sera investi et donc au mans qui peuvent
faire campagne de vouloir mettre sous
silence c'est vraiment en outre passe
clairement leurs fonctions et une
protection qui est tout à fait
arbitraire dont il a ça tu dont ils
jouissent qui à la section 2 130 du code
de communication aux états unis qui leur
permet voilà de ne pas être responsable
de leurs propos dans l'avion il n'est
dit pas le fait de censure et de
promouvoir tel ou tel contenu
ils interviennent donc comme des furies
shirts comme des des plateformes plus
comme des plateformes et donc du coup il
va être redevable cela la vraie question
c'est
le soul soul de ce titre à ça c'est que
trump a eu un succès absolument
considérable sur l'ensemble des réseaux
sociaux grâce à son application et à sa
manière de communiquer un peu hors
normes il l'a lui-même fait tirer de
d'un aspect un peu moribond twitter
durant tout son mandat et il faut
reconnaître que depuis qu'il n'y ait
plus il ya eu une vague de départs plus
ou moins volontaire mais que ce réseau
et d'autres perdre un peu de leur
intérêt de leur saveur donc on voit
quand même qu'il ya une vraie volonté de
c2c de ces médias avec leur parti-pris
libéral comprendre leur parti pris
gauchisant de passer sous couvert d
idées plutôt que d'être ouvert à une
confrontation point de vue dans une
discussion aussi lisez donc ce qui
concerne donc les outils faut quand même
reconnaître qu'il ya ces outils censés
les superpuissances c'est un peu comme
des demi-dieux ils font le jeu puis elle
beau temps vivre sans facebook que vous
soyez politique ou commerçants c'est
absolument inenvisageable
donc il ya d'autres projets qui sont en
cours et faut pas exclure que encore une
fois la force et la détermination du
parti républicain et des alliés donald
trump puisse permettre de répondre
savoie au plus grand nombre une
doublette 700 réseaux sociaux est ce que
donald trump peut faire son retour en
politique est ce qu'aujourd'hui il est
réellement amputée du fait de n'être
plus sur les réseaux sociaux
oui aujourd'hui il est en kit est pas ce
que c'est ces réseaux 167 sont façon de
communiquer qui étaient tellement
efficaces programmes sont présidentes
s'est continuellement fait des tweets
il n'a plus est utile de communication
mais en revanche il est très rusé et les
choses évoluent et il est possible il va
trouver un autre moyen de connecter avec
le grand public pour l'instant il
communique avec sa base et ça représente
un tiers de l'électorat mais vos réussi
son pari comme il a vite fait avant il
faut avoir un accès sus direct aux tirs
2 non déclarés
c'est un jeu de légende qui nous
identifier ni démocrates ni républicaine
ils sont les gars fin il n'a pas la
capacité de toucher cet auditeur merci à
l'assiette professeur de droit et
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines nicolas kert ce porte parole
à des républicains envers six france
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir avec mon frère tu es
france